select this message has gone to some of
you guys that feel like you're all by
yourself and no one's around you because
you're trying to chase your dreams and
your ambitions but you feel like you're
all by yourself let me explain some to
you I'm in my car right now obviously no
one is sitting next to me no one's
behind me the only thing I got is this
light here if I close this it's off it's
like openness it's on I'm on myself
there's only one person I can talk to
here so what does this mean here's what
it means the first couple years of your
business you are gonna get to a moment
where this happens to you you can't call
your wife
you can't call your husband boyfriend
girlfriend you know why because you told
them you have big dreams and ambitions
and they believed you and they said go
for it
you can't call your friends because you
told your friends you got big plans you
cannot call your peers you cannot call
anybody not your parents because you're
told your parents I don't want to go to
college and become a lawyer I don't want
to pursue and become that engineer I
want to go become a businessman a
salesperson or an entrepreneur and then
all of a sudden you find yourself in a
car like this all by yourself
talking to only one person and it's you
and what do you do at this point I've
been in these types of situations many
many times so you sit together by
yourself at kuang appointments two-hour
drive three our job I'm knocking on the
door of the person to sell something
that I want to make fifteen hundred
dollars that I need that fifteen hundred
dollars to make my car payment my
cellphone payment and pay off my credit
card for that month and I'm knocking on
the door I see the drape move in they
don't open the door for me and I drove
two and a half hours of traffic I said I
see you they're not opening the door
sir I see you not open your door I'm
calling they're not picking up they're
pressing again I call again they're
pressing end what are you doing that
moment are you doing that moment you
know what I'm talking about what are you
then a moment what are you doing to go
all these sales calls or you do all
these other things you prepared a
proposal you put so much time into
you're like oh my gosh this is gonna
make me $5,000 this is gonna make me
$2,500 or $10,000 and it doesn't go your
way then after that appointment or the
meeting or all day are making calls
sending emails and anything you do all
day there's gonna come a time you get in
your car and you're by yourself what are
you telling your stuff when you're in a
car by yourself
here's what it sounds like is this even
gonna work for me
is this even worth it why am I doing
this why am i putting me my body through
this what is this all about why not just
go get a break get a job and just have a
peaceful life I mean what is really a
big deal about having all the money
anyways
most people who have money are miserable
anyways who cares about making millions
who cares about traveling the world who
cares about any of this stuff why do I
care about having a Ferrari I don't need
to buy a Ferrari anyways pay more money
pay more tax have a big Russ I don't
care why do I need to have a legacy who
cares about having a big legacy why do I
need to do that stuff why Who am I
trying to prove a point to why why am I
trying to prove a point that I got this
in in those moments is whether you win
or you lose because of what you tell
yourself because you don't do you it's
here where you become your own Ally I
remember I would sit in an appointment
that'll go to an appointee wouldn't work
and I come to my car and I was sit back
and I like oh my gosh
and I would close my eyes and I would
visualize what this life is gonna look
like and I would have to shut my eyes to
believe in the dream that I have and my
visualization would go imagine a
conversation having with your dad with
your mom with your family imagine those
moments where they say you're proud of
you they're proud of you imagine you're
looking at yourself in the mirror you're
surprised yourself you're seeing your
kids one day private school traveling to
get you got great relationship they want
to be around you they enjoy your company
then later on grandkids and you've done
such a good job and the legacy they're
so proud of their last names you've made
the money where he can go on the family
times to get if something happens to
them we got the resources I would go and
I would be in this stream of mine and
every single time I got to that point
rather than dwelling and asking those
questions I would go and dream every
time I did that you know what it was
like was that going to Chevron gas
station like going to shell like going
to Arco even Olga doesn't take credit
cards so I go into those places and you
would dream and you refueled and then
you go back up again but the challenge
is most people when they hit these
moments they don't go to the gas station
unfortunately to get to these moments
they get to illogical and when they get
to a logical guess what ends up
happening
they make logical decisions not
emotional decisions thinking about their
bigger dreams and when they make the
logical decisions they all of a sudden
quit and they go away and they go back
and they retract to what they were doing
before and maybe you're on everybody
people could say you made the right
decision for the rest of your life
there's only one person's gonna do that
you quit you know that one person is you
and gradually a little bit of bitterness
man through your body because you're
upset you quit she refuses a little
shorter you're a little bit more upset
people are wondering why no one knows
why your wife asks you it's on your mind
sometimes I don't know what you're
thinking miss out nothing about nothing
yeah you are I know you're thinking I'm
not thinking nothing you're leaving it
on I'm not thinking nothing right now
baby I've been married to you for six
years you're thinking about something
what is the matter with you leave me
alone
what's on your mind babe no one's gonna
know you are gonna know so what's the
moral of the story here with this video
next time you're by yourself in the car
no one else is Ron thinks I'm going your
way you got to find a way to hype
yourself up you got to find your way to
focus on division you got to find your
way to refined a way to remind yourself
of the dream and refuel yourself or else
you're eventually gonna go around and be
around all the crowd once you're around
all the crowd you're going backwards
because to get to the next crowd you
kind of got to graduate this company
because the reality is now that you make
it you have so many people around you
that think like you support you help you
to bind into the vision they have
respect for you because they've seen the
toughness that you have because if see
you're somebody to follow you're
somebody to team up with you were
running they type of a person then all
of us in are like wait a minute
I thought it was all by myself where'd
all these people show up that's because
you never quit so message is very simple
whatever you're doing if you're in a
situation like this you are not alone
many other people have been in
situations like this it's almost
mandatory to get to the next level
except day one in these moments and I
challenge you
do the same as well having said that
have a great week this week wonderful
week this week and we'll do this again
next week take everybody bye-bye
[Music]